President Trump has signed a
proclamation directing National Guard
troops to be deployed along the US
border with Mexico the president said
last night that a drastic surge of
illegal activity left his administration
no choice but to act governor's along
the border support the move but some
members of Congress questioned it and
it's still unclear what exactly those
troops will do when they get to the
border chip Reid is at the White House
chip good morning good morning this will
be the third time a president has sent
the National Guard to assist the Border
Patrol but the details are still up in
the air including how many troops and
how long they will be deployed the
threat is real homeland security
secretary Kirsten nielsen said Wednesday
Guard members will be sent to the border
soon Department of Defense and the
Department of Homeland Security work
together with our governor's to deploy
the National Guard to our southwest
border to assist the Border Patrol but
she could not say how big the force
would be when they'd be deployed or for
how long it will be strong it will be as
many as is needed to fill the gaps that
we have today is what I can't tell you
in a memo the president called the
situation on the us-mexico border a
point of crisis and wrote that the
lawlessness that continues at our
southern border is fundamentally
incompatible with the safety security
and sovereignty of the American people
the Congressional Hispanic Caucus fired
back calling the president's actions
unwarranted and saying they will
ultimately undermine our military
readiness federal law prohibits the u.s.
military from acting as law enforcement
they cannot arrest illegal border
crossers and can only act in a support
capacity Nielson said the effort would
be similar to a 2006 operation when
President George W Bush sent six
thousand troops to assist border patrol
in 2010 President Obama also sent
National Guard members to the southern
border senior administration officials
said illegal crossings were at a quote
staggering high in March the urgency
cannot however be underscored it's time
to act
it's not clear how many people illegally
crossed the border last month but
Customs and Border Protection says
apprehensions rose by 200 percent this
March compared to March of 2017 however
for this year's
so far apprehensions are down compared
to the same point last year chip read
for us at the White House Thank You chip